[Music]
i don't think people realized
um
consciously until the last few months
how
much
uh
the this idea that man is not good for
men to be alone
that this isolation
uh from other people
how uh psychologically damaging it is
and it was re it's also revealing
simultaneously to me the weak spots in
uh this social media
where people don't have real friends
they have facebook friends and by the
way your facebook friends are not real
friends they're fake friends
okay and so unless they also happen to
be your friend who you actually see
in the flesh and look at them in their
real eyes
and that kind of thing and so your
followers on instagram are not real
that's not real that's right i've got i
got what have i got two million on
instagram yeah and you know how many of
them i know personally three
[Laughter]
yeah you and james and kelly you and
james and kelly that's three my wife
yeah rachel yeah i know all of y'all oh
my wife doesn't follow me so i don't
know and so
and uh you know and and you know you get
these it's funny so many people that
think they know something about social
media go oh ramsay you're you're doing
this all wrong man you only follow 33
people and you have 2 million people
following you you're supposed to follow
a bazillion people man you're doing it
all wrong i'm like no you you're doing
it wrong
because you forgot the idea that human
connection is a big deal it's everything
that's why we're relishing going to
football games yeah that's why we're
relishing going to an eagles concert
it's while we're relishing going to a
ramsey smart conference because we're in
the presence of other human beings that
have like-minded
uh goals and values and we're aiming at
something together
we're not sitting somewhere looking at a
screen
and calling it a conversation somebody i
was on an interview the other day and
they asked me was the tr it was about
trauma and
the interviewer asked me dude i think
this trauma that we just experienced
we're experiencing coming out of was on
par with 911
as a country and i said no i think this
one's actually worse oh definitely
because 911 we had at least we had the
whether it's an illusion we had a common
enemy yeah and it was them and this time
it was
well maybe that woman walking her dog
might kill me or maybe my kid coming
home from school i'm like what's
happening and we weaponized each other
right i went to get
you know i went to buy a loaf of bread
milk and eggs
and all sudden you know i'm a villain
yeah or someone's going to kill you or
you're going to kill all these other
people and we weaponized the most core
human function
which is human connection it just turned
into a weapon and then it got
politicized and then we all it went
crazy it went crazy and we went from
flattening the curve to masking to
vaccine to beating each other up with
the curve to everything else and just
panicking yeah and the the uh the the it
was
yeah it was much more devastating than
911 yeah
to the culture yeah to the culture it's
gonna be a long time digging out of this
one
but there's the antidote it's other
people is relationships in person all
day every day real relationships in
person this is the antidote so not only
what happened there but what has
happened with the this fake social media
revolution is being exposed now as fake
yep uh facebook's tanking consequently
it's tanking
uh because people are starting to go is
not real well that's why we called it
virtual well
it's back in the day when they used to
give my granddad i think it was one of
his teachers or a coach gave him
cigarettes because it calmed him down
when he was 10. and
it worked it did and then we realized oh
that'll kill you too right so yeah this
was all fun and games for a couple of 10
years or 15 years till we realized oh
man it's going to kill us all so yeah we
got to get back in the same room with
each other talk to each other again
and you know attend some things i'm
making myself go do i think in the
presence
and i'm making our organization start to
do these events yeah and even if it's
uncomfortable and even if some of you
out there are pissed off just go ahead
and get really pissed off because we're
doing it
okay because i i know you're scared and
i understand you're scared i'm sorry
you're scared but we're doing it we're
gonna get back out here and help people
again and move the dead gum needle and
if you don't like that well you don't
have to come it's that easy come anyway
but we'd like to have you anyway come
anyway well don't come if you're
miserable don't come don't make
everybody